♪ C'était l'époque
d'Internet de l'époque ♪
♪ À l'époque,
il n'y avait pas les pokes ♪
♪ On ne googlisait pas,
on lycossait sur Lycos ♪
♪ On se donnait rencard
le soir sur MSN ♪
♪ Pour s'envoyer des wizz ♪
♪ Les téléphones
n'avaient pas de 4G ♪
♪ C'était des téléphones
pour téléphoner ♪
♪ Et faire de la muscu ♪
♪ C'était l'époque
des connexions pourries ♪
♪ Et il y avait des boules
dans nos souris ♪
♪ Il n'y avait pas Tinder ♪
♪ Ni même adopteunmec ♪
♪ Du coup, pour pécho,
on chattait sur Caramail ♪
♪ Ou sur voila.fr ♪
♪ On avait des pseudos,
mais pas de photo de profil ♪
♪ Pour s'rencontrer en vrai,
c'était difficile ♪
Donc, nono26, c'est toi ?
>> C'est ça, c'est moi.
Et toi, t'es bombasseblondedu75 ?
>> Oui !
♪ C'était l'époque
où quand tu surfais ♪
♪ Tes parents
ne pouvaient pas téléphoner ♪
Norman !
Raccroche ton Internet !
♪ Ni Deezer, ni Spotify ♪
♪ C'était le temps de Winamp ♪
♪ LimeWire, Morpheus,
eMule Donkey ♪
♪ Shareaza ou Kazaa♪
♪ Télécharger un film en
trois semaines sans break ♪
♪ Une fois sur deux,
on tombait sur un fake ♪
Je savais pas qu'il y avait
cette scène dans Toy Story...
C'est hyper bien fait !
On aimerait bien y être !
♪ À l'époque,
on avait des disquettes ♪
♪ On allait sur le net
avec Netscape ♪
♪ Pas de Wikipédia ♪
♪ On consultait Encarta ♪
♪ Internet, c'était pas très connu ♪
♪ Et en particulier,
par les profs du bahut ♪
♪ Pour les exposés,
on pouvait copier-coller ♪
♪ Sans se faire gauler ♪
Alors, Norman, c'est incroyable,
de 3, vous êtes passé à 20/20 !
Ben, moi, j'aime vraiment tout ce qui est Mésopotamie
mérovingienne,  c'est vraiment mon délire, quoi !
Bah, c'est incroyable ! Bravo ! Je suis fière de vous,
Norman ! C'est un truc de ouf, mon gars, sûr !
♪ C'était l'époque
où on gravait des CD ♪
♪ Des CD vierges
un peu comme ma verge ♪
♪ Il n'y avait pas YouPorn, XVidéos ou xHamster ♪
♪ Les sites pour adultes
étaient un peu nuls ♪
♪ Il n'y avait que des images ♪
♪ Avec la connexion,
le chargement était si long ♪
♪ Que bien souvent on
kiffait sur un chignon ♪
Oh merde !
Merde ! Oh oh oh !
♪ C'était l'époque
des téléphones fixes ♪
♪ Au petit-déjeuner,
on mangeait des Kix ♪
♪ Il n'y avait même pas Ebay ♪
♪ Certains se souviennent de iBazar ♪
♪ Avant, tout le monde
trouvait ça stylé ♪
♪ D'avoir une page myspace ♪
♪ Avec Tom,
on était tous amis ♪
♪ Ce mec n'avait
qu'une seule photo de lui ♪
Hé, Tom !
>> Ouais ?
Hi hi !
>> Mais attends, j'étais pas prêt, là !
Oh, c'est bon, c'est pas grave, c'est pas comme si
t'allais garder cette photo toute ta vie !
Ha ha, c'est clair !
♪ C'était l'époque
d'Internet d'avant ♪
♪ Internet d'avant,
Copains d'avant ♪
♪ Pas de
Nyan Cat ♪
♪ Avec Hugo,
on commençait les vidéos ♪
♪ À l'époque,
y avait pas de Nabilla ♪
♪ Nous, y avait des vrais buzz, Madame ♪
♪ Y avait Star Wars, Killer, Ninja,
Gibul et bien sûr Kamini ♪
♪ Je venais pas de la cité,
mais le beat était bon ♪
♪ Je venais pas de Paname,
mais de Marly-Gomont ♪
♪ Purée, c'était la belle époque,
ça, Madame ♪
♪ Je me rappelle,
il y avait aussi lui ♪
♪ Ingénieur informaticien ♪
♪ Hé ouais mon petit gars,
on avait deux heures de forfait par mois ♪
♪ Nous, chez LibertySurf, Alice,
Wanadoo, AOL ou Club Internet ♪
♪ Et y avait pas de wifi,
que des modems d'56k ♪
♪ On s'envoyait pas les snapchats,
pas de sextos ♪
♪ Nous on montrait
nos b*tes, en vrai ♪
♪ Allez, chauffe,
PV, chauffe ! ♪
Attends, tu veux me voir sur scène ?
Mais y a pas de souci.
Viens voir mon spectacle "Norman sur scène",
que je joue actuellement dans toute la France.
Et je joue aussi à Paris, au Palace,
à partir du 15 octobre 2015.
Pour prendre directement ta place, eh ben
tu cliques sur le petit lien dans la description,
tout simplement. Tu verras,
je suis hyper marrant, c'est abusé !